the premise of the movie is set in the
1950s in the united states although on
paper african-americans have equal
rights in reality they are facing raging
racism and segregation one victim of
such racism is a middle-aged black woman
named ruby baptiste at the beginning of
the film she is looking for a job in her
predominantly white city while in the
same venture she ends up at marshall
field a department store that used to be
popular for its anti-black agenda ruby
finds another black woman working in the
store who they have appointed to seem
more inclusive in changing times she
knows that the store will not allow two
black girls to work in the same
department hence she doesn't bother
going in for the interview later that
day ruby is working at a pub as a side
hustle it is a safe environment for
black people since it lies in their part
of the town however among the crowd a
white man catches ruby's attention he
even pays for her drinks an act that
intrigues her ruby introduces herself
and asks him what his intentions are the
man's name is william and he claims that
he has no bad intentions towards her as
they talk the topic of being a black
woman in america is brought up ruby
expresses that because she is black she
is competing with her own people to get
a job if she had williams skin she
wouldn't have to run as fast as she is
running right now by the end of the
night it is evident that william fancies
ruby which is uncommon because of their
races ruby takes the chance and decides
to come home with him soon things get
steamy and they end up making love on
the steps then comes the morning ruby
wakes up and gets a look at her arms
which have miraculously turned white
shocked she walks up to the mirror to
discover that she has completely turned
into a white woman she slaps herself to
get out of the nightmare and only after
several attempts does she register that
this is reality she freaks out and goes
outside in just a robe but unlike usual
no one pays much attention to her while
frantically trying to make sense of the
situation she bumps into a black kid he
drops his popcorn everywhere but the
white cops nearby restrain him instead
of ruby this is when she experiences
white privilege for the first time
before the kid is harmed she tells the
cops it was her fault however they are
not regretful of accusing the child just
because he is black they politely escort
her to the police car to bring her home
ruby is unused to being treated so
kindly by police but she is too shocked
to make sense of what is going on at
last they find out she is william's
friend and bring her to his house again
it turns out that the officers have been
told that ruby is william's wife and is
mentally ill when she discovers that
they are taking her back to williams she
tries to escape she has to stop because
of sharp pain in her body that almost
knocks her out in the following scene
william brings her inside a room and
lays her down on the floor ruby is still
screaming in pain oblivious to what is
happening to her body then her bones
crackle and she starts transforming into
her older self william helps her with
the transformation by cutting her with a
kitchen knife her skin sheds and it is
revealed that she is the same ruby under
her white skin after the situation dies
down ruby is still weak so she rests on
his bed while william tells her what is
going on he starts by explaining
metamorphosis a process that changes a
caterpillar into a butterfly the same
process can be performed in humans which
is how ruby turned into a white woman he
also asks her to rest assured because
the transformation is reversible and
only works if she drinks a potion from
time to time he further explains that
the potion is not scientific it is
magical just when he says this black
butterflies fly above ruby some years
ago william was working to apply
metamorphosis to humans but his practice
was laughed at because it didn't seem
practical to his colleagues that was
only until he met a man who had a secret
to the universe and who gave him the
potion ruby has a hard time taking
everything in and is shocked to learn
that magic is real now that the pain is
gone she can clearly spot the difference
in how she was treated as a white woman
she felt like she was finally a human
being however the pain was not worth it
william assures her it will get easier
starting the second time a while later
he leaves but not before leaving ruby a
vial of potion and a bundle of money he
wants her to do anything she likes with
them after giving it some thought ruby
decides to drink the potion and go
outside as an entirely different person
she enjoys the day by strolling around
the park without getting any
uncomfortable stares i guess misogyny
doesn't exist in this world little
things like buying ice cream is a
different experience as a white woman
she isn't feared or judged because of
her skin color ruby discovers what
freedom feels like for the first time in
her life at night she has turned into
her original self and is taking a bath
in william's house william finds her in
a good mood and assumes her day went
well he is also curious as to why she
didn't take the money that he left for
her ruby replies that after her skin
turned white she didn't need the money
anymore william discloses that when the
time comes she will have to do a favor
for him but assures her that it isn't
something drastic until then she is free
to live or come to his house anytime she
wishes the following day ruby changes
her name to hillary and applies for a
job at the same department store that
she couldn't get as a black woman she is
interviewed by the general manager paul
her resume is impressive because she has
studied and worked hard to succeed as an
african-american woman an impressed paul
even jokes that she might take his
job aside from the formal questions she
is asked how she feels about working
with colored people ruby replies that as
long as they are qualified she doesn't
care satisfied with the answer paul
offers her a job as an assistant manager
as paul continues to chat ruby feels
herself transforming back to her
original self she quickly makes up an
excuse and escapes the situation
thankfully she manages to get into an
elevator before fully turning later that
week she starts working as the assistant
manager a position so high not even the
most qualified black woman could acquire
it paul welcomes her by kissing her hand
and is overly friendly to her sometimes
but since ruby is drowning in the high
of being white she hardly notices his
advances after that she goes to tamara
the black woman whose employment hurt
her chances last time although she was
the reason ruby didn't get the job she
doesn't hold a grudge against her own
people in fact ruby makes sure to remind
tamara that she has been appointed
because of her qualifications and she
shouldn't let anyone undermine that in
reply tamara reveals that she is a high
school dropout the confession sends ruby
into a moral dilemma she has always
preached that employment should be based
on one's qualifications but seeing her
own people miss using the power she is
left confused on what side she is on
later on ruby is with her female
colleagues in the back room trying on
clothes and dancing together the white
women are shocked at how well she dances
upon finding out that she has been to a
club in a predominantly black area they
urge her to take them as well let's
appropriate some culture they say ruby
is shocked because she had thought white
women would dread being around black
people but it turns out they are
interested in black culture but are
unwilling to accept them as people
the following day ruby finds tamara not
doing her job right she scolds the girl
saying that she can only be an asset to
her race if she is better at her job
since it is coming from a white woman
tamera thinks the message is
condescending and racist as ruby
continues yelling at her paul interrupts
them asking if everything is all right
ruby immediately composes herself and
says that tamara was just offering to
show them around the black pub later
that day after work paul tamara ruby and
the three white women go to the club
listening to her white colleagues
talking about black people and culture
ruby feels disheartened she has started
to lose a sense of originality in the
first week of being a white woman when
no one is looking she goes outside and
breaks the vial of potion with her hands
this turns her back into a black woman
and she feels much better than she did
earlier just then she hears a noise in
the background upon peeking through a
hole she sees paul forcing himself onto
tamara this reminds ruby of all the
times he has looked down upon tamara
calling her names behind her back and
insulting her for being black he is so
desperate that he is taking advantage of
a helpless girl ruby burns in anger but
before she can do anything tamara takes
a stand for herself she bites paul's lip
and gets free from his hold in the
following scene ruby is sitting on
william's couch covered in her own blood
from frequent transformation from the
basement door comes a beautiful girl
named christina ruby has seen her once
or twice before and assumes that she is
william's assistant christina says that
she knows what ruby is going through but
in turn ruby claims she will never
understand the pain of being black
christina agrees but asserts that
william didn't give her the potion so
she could turn white he gave her the
potions so she could do everything she
wanted to as a black woman this changes
ruby's perspective for the past week she
has been trying hard to do things as a
white person and has forgotten what she
would do in their place as a black woman
the following day ruby turns into helen
for the last time and goes to the office
to hand in her resignation paul is
shocked that a new and competent girl
like her is leaving so soon however ruby
explains that she is attracted to paul
and the only way for her to be together
with him is as a lover not as his
employee paul unable to control himself
kisses her but ruby stops him asking him
to be more patient she wants to turn him
into a toy and make him long for her
before she gives in she ties his hands
and pulls his pants down as paul looks
at her in anticipation she ties his belt
around his neck and treats him like a
dog paul is enjoying the moment until he
notices her eyes are changing colors he
asks her to stop but she ignores him and
stuffs his mouth with a gag so he cannot
scream then she proceeds to assault him
with her stiletto heel by the end of the
torture her white skin is completely
peeled off and she is covered in blood
again this is getting wild in the
following scene ruby finds william at
home coming out of the basement she has
seen him and christina come and go from
the basement several times moreover it
is the only place in the house with a
lock she inquires what is going on down
there suddenly william falls to the
ground in pain to ruby's shock he goes
into metamorphosis and turns into
christina it is then revealed that
christina is her true form and she turns
into william because of the potion she
brings ruby into the basement where the
real william and hilary are attached to
machines christina uses their blood to
create the potion which she further puts
into use to disguise herself as william
it is revealed that christina was a
scientist working with a group of men
who never believed in her she was also
discriminated against because of her
gender so she changed herself into
william and reached an immense height of
success ruby is shocked by the
revelation and realizes that christina
has lost herself because of the magic
she also comes to terms that she doesn't
need the potion anymore because she
doesn't want to be white she has learned
to embrace her skin color no matter how
she is treated because of it all that
matters is that she doesn't lose her
integrity and pride subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching